goasguen
président ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'intérieur et elle porte
sur les lieux de culte musulman je
voudrais vous rappeler les propos que
vous avez tenus lors du débat
parlementaire du mois de juillet dans un
article du 1er août vous avez considéré
qu'une vingtaine de mosquées et salles
de prière avait été fermée depuis
décembre 2015 le même article signifier
qu'il y avait 120 salles de prière et
mosquées diffusant une idéologie
salafistes au sens général du terme
depuis cette période et malgré les
questions nombreuses pauses et en
particulier les miennes vous n'avez qu'à
nous n'avons quasiment reçu aucune
information sur les décisions prises de
fermeture de mosquées de lieux de culte
ce mutisme vous le reconnaîtrez monsieur
le ministre dans le climat actuel ne
peut qu'inquiéter une population qui vit
en état d'urgence question question que
se posent les français que s'est il
passé depuis le 1er août combien de
mosquées et de lieux de culte ont été
fermés combien d'associations salafistes
ont été sanctionnés 10 août combien de
fameuse école madrasa ont été
sanctionnés il est évident que votre
silence témoigne d'un certain embarras
et je pense d'ailleurs que les
difficultés d'ordre juridique sont
probablement très importante nous avions
signalé lors du débat le 21 juillet que
l'article 6 et l'article 8 de la loi sur
l'état d'urgence ne vous permettrai pas
de toute évidence et serait insuffisant
dans ce domaine puisque devant les
attaques terroristes nous apercevons que
ce silence est vraisemblablement liée à
certains atermoiements devant les
tribunaux du moins je l'espère où peut
pas croire objectivement on ne peut pas
croire aujourd'hui que dans l'état
actuel des choses tout d'un coup les
mosquées salafistes soit devenu un
endroit
fréquentable donc la question que je me
pose monsieur le ministre où en
êtes-vous sur les chiffres où en
êtes-vous sur les décisions juridiques
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire de ce
point de vue merci dans la mesure où la
parole est à monsieur jean marie le guen
secrétaire d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement le député goasguen
bien évidemment
le but d'une politique de lutte contre
le terrorisme est aussi évidemment
contre la radicalisation n'est pas en
soi de fermer tel ou tel lieu de culte
parce que de temps en temps la manière
dont nous entendions les choses on
pensait que c'était en soi un objectif
mais vous avez attiré l'attention
évidemment du gouvernement et vous avez
centre et votre propos sur un certain
nombre de mosquées qui pourrait abriter
c'est comme ça que je le comprends des
prêcheurs de l et là dessus je vais vous
répondre précisément avec des chiffres
pour vous dire comment et nous mettons
en oeuvre effectivement une politique
qui vise à écarter ces prêcheurs de
haine de leurs possibilités en même
temps et vous le reconnaîtrez avec moi
nous sommes ici pour préserver aussi la
liberté de culte je tiens à le rappeler
et pour faire en sorte également que des
procès d'intention d'ordre purement
intellectuel ne soit pas mieux mais que
juridiquement vous l'avez rappelé les
choses soient fondées alors monsieur le
député je tiens à vous dire que neuf
mosquées ou salles de prière radicaliser
ont été faits refermer sur le fondement
de l'article 8 de la loi du 3 avril 55
relatives à l'état d'urgence à l'état
d'urgence trois associations
prétendument voué à l'exercice du culte
ont fait l'objet d'une dissolution en
conseil des ministres sur le fondement
des 6ème et 7ème point de l'article 221
de la sécurité intérieure et bonne
nouvelle allant dans le sens de la
solidification de notre droit en quelque
sorte le tribunal administratif de melun
a confirmé vendredi dernier la validité
de l'arrêté de la fermeture de cette
mosquée ceci est à rapporter évidemment
au fait que précédemment il n'y avait eu
aucune fermeture de mosquées que nous
sommes en train en quelque sorte non
seulement d'agir mais de créer du droit
qui va dans le sens des cartes et les
prêcheurs de haine merci la parole est à
madame monique